thanks for being here I appreciate last
session of the day last session of the
conference I'm sure you're quite tired
worn out but a good conference so far
good excellent all right we'll try to
enter the bang so my name is Tim Corey
this is what we're talking about vs code
for c-sharp developers
um I've got a little bit of PowerPoint
to go through just to kind of set as a
baseline for why all right and then
we're going to dive into the actual code
most this session is going to be code
um think about your questions we'll
answer at the end I'll try and save some
time for you
um we probably got here early but I'll
try and at least get you out of here on
time I know that you know you want to
get the next thing and keep moving so
why why use vs code
um Visual Studio the full Visual Studio
is the best tool at least free for
working with C sharp yes there are tools
like writer
um but why we use vs code it seemed like
a step down it seems like it's a smaller
tool so why use vs code let's start the
first one it's very very fast if you've
ever opened up visual studio and going
out in coffee then come back and then
hope that your stuff was lowered by that
point vs code is very very fast why is
this important well for one if we have a
a code base where we just want like a
small change okay we just did you know
we spied a bug we make a small change
maybe you're not even on your laptop or
your PC you can just download you know
good go to get do a git clone download
the code open up the VS code make the
change publish to back to get and you're
good to go so it's very very fast in
fact I did a little experiment a little
bit ago I'm going to publish the video
at some point soon where I went out and
bought a Raspberry Pi and a keyboard
form so it's a hundred dollars at the
time Raspberry Pi and I said what can we
do with this and so I put vs code on
there I put the net SDK on there and I
started building web apps and it worked
great so in a little keyboard factor a
hundred dollars plus your monitor I was
up and running with vs code so vs code
is a great platform for just getting
stuff quick if you have an older PC if
you have you know something that's dying
but you can still get vs code running
you can still do C sharp development
number two cross-platform it's on
Windows it's on Mac it's on Linux it's
in the cloud you can put vs code
practically everywhere like I said a
Raspberry Pi can run vs code and so
when you're working with your your C
sharp again you might not always have
your machine might not always be on a
machine where it's your full development
suite and so being able to work
cross-platform is a great luxury also
that cross platform experience is
basically the same across the entire
Suite of of operating systems
this is one that people miss this is why
I really encourage everybody even if you
have a great machine even if you're
working at your desk even if you have
full Visual Studio I encourage you to
drop down into vs code once in a while
it's going to open your eyes
because when you start working with your
c-sharp code where you start building
your c-sharp code you're going to start
saying wait what
how do I do that again for example one
of the things I love about vs code is
you say file just new file and just says
what's the name that's it I mean you
don't have this whole dialogue and
dialing through different things you
just say hey I want a new file and so I
say you know personmodel.cs the downside
there is you're presented the blank file
do you know what goes in there
do you know what how to put a namespace
and how structure your class properly do
you know how to scaffold out the basics
of that file well it's going to push
those c-sharp skills sometimes pushing
the basics that you think you just you
just know and kind of pushing you and
know them better and so that's why I
encourage you to use it at least once in
a while and finally It prepares you for
your CI CD process
if you've ever used GitHub actions or
you built a Docker container or other
processes where you're putting your
c-sharp into your
um this build process where you have to
script out what happens
you don't want the the first time you've
ever seen the.net command line because
when you build out a GitHub action and
you start typing out those command lines
if you don't know what's going on you
put it in and you push it up and you run
it and you wait and you wait and you
wait and it fails
and you go oh I missed a space here a
comma here something else here and to
make a change and then you push it up
and you wait and you wait and you wait
and you wait and then it fails again and
so by having to use vs code you've also
used the.net command line you're more
ready to move on to these these build
processes where it uses the command line
in order to build out your application
so
that or my that's my four reasons for
why I should use vs code whatever your
using reason for using vs code let's
actually see it in action
okay so like I said I'm not a big
PowerPoint guy we're going to dump the
PowerPoint at that point and let's start
with just opening up the terminal
now the first thing is on the terminal
is this big enough for everybody
yes in the back good okay
so the first thing with the terminal is
if you haven't already
learn this code space Dot
whatever folder you're in
that opens vs code in that folder super
helpful we're going to do that quite a
bit we're going to leave the terminal
open I prefer especially in demos to use
this terminal
as opposed to come on give me the corner
as opposed to the um the terminal inside
of
oh goodness
um inside of the
vs code now you can go into vs code if
you hit your control in the uh tilde
it pulls up the the terminal you can use
that if you want but I again I prefer
especially in demos to have the I think
is the nicer view terminal
all right so the first thing we're going
to do is you need to make sure that you
have a net SDK installed on your
computer to do that you can say dot net
all one word that command is like the
command to know dot n-e-t then you can
do whatever you want so in this case
dash dash info
and this tells me what's installed so we
have currently we're on Windows it says
on Windows 10 but that's just because
it's Windows 11.
um it says that we're on the.net SDK of
7.0.102 and we have the following
runtimes installed five six and seven
all right so that tells you what's
installed if you don't have an SDK
installed you can just Google it
you'll get to this right here just
google.net SDK download you'll get to
this and with this it's going to show
you the supported versions and you just
download whichever SDK is right for your
platform this will change if you're on
Mac run links
there's also the auto support versions
so you can even go back if you want to
a.net core 1.0 and cry
so it's up to you all right so with that
the other thing is if you don't have vs
code go to visualstudio.com
and right there
download it for practically any platform
okay
back to the demo so you have net dash
dash info
let's talk now about how we want to
create a new project now
what I'm going to do in this demo is
create a few projects from scratch I
don't anticipate you'll all do that all
the time I don't anticipate that you use
vs code for everything that you do but
if I walk through all the steps then
whatever you need to do one of those
steps you'll know how to do that okay
so
let's start with where do you start
well.net new
dot net new is the place to start to
create anything but if you don't know
what to create
dot net new
list
all right
and that you have to add two dashes for
that let's actually clear the screen and
start it again
so it's dash dash list
there we go and if we maximize this we
have a little better of a view
these are all the templates that are
installed on my computer and yes you can
create any of these using the command
line
so we're going to do a few of these
today there's some fun ones hidden in
here that you might not think about
so first of
all.net new
gets ignore
now if you ever create a git ignore file
you know that there's a lot that has to
go into it for visual studio for vs code
for net in general
or you can just do that
okay so we go back to our vs code and
look we have a ignore file
that has uh hundreds
yeah 477 lines of ignore stuff all right
if we searched I actually searched
earlier in here is your vs code entries
so it has vs code entries it has Visual
Studio entries it's designed to work
with everything.net
all right so with one
command line you create that
all right so now let's create a net
new solution sln so we're going to start
with let's start with simple demo
you have to name it it's all right dash
dash name okay so dot net new sln for
solution the nice give it dash dash name
to name my solution I call it simple
demo
and if you go back over to vs code we
now have a solution file solution file
has nothing with it but at least you
have a solution file
so let's actually put something in it so
net new console and again.net new and
then dash dash list will give you
whatever thing you need and then you
start running these commands
name so I'll call this console UI
all right so let's create the console
for us let's shrink this back down and
look over here we have a console
application
get a good start and now we want to
associate the the Cs project file with a
solution file because those don't come
Associated out of the box
so we say is dot net sln and give it the
solution name which is simple demo Dot
slm we say add
console UI slash console
ui.csproch
okay now I'm using Powershell if using
bash there are ways to do the glob
pattern in order to say just hey give me
every CS project file associated with
the solution okay but with Powershell
you can't do that
all right so now we have the two
associated with each other
we go back over here to our console UI
look at program.cs
all right we have our our normal
program.cs and this pops up
so what this is it says hey you're
missing some build assets
well this is not from vs code it's
actually from a c-sharp extension we hit
yes for this let's go over to our
extensions and look
and right here this is the this is the
one extension you really need to have
installed if you're working with c-sharp
in vs code and that's the C sharp
extension it does come from Microsoft
it's actually powered by Omni Sharp all
right so with that extension installed
once it sees a valid program.cs then
it's going to say hey I want to scaffold
out some things and it's going to put it
in the dot vs code folder the benefit
there is that this is only for vs code
it gets ignored by git and your if the
specific to your machine it's not going
to impact your source code which means
that if you have source code that you
usually use in visual studio and you
open up in vs code you're not going to
have an impact negatively on your source
code just because you open it up this is
all separate but what's in here let's
take a peek
we have two files we have task.json we
have launch.json we're going to play
more around us in just a minute but
first let's do this let's go over to our
C sharp code and first let's just run so
we hit F5
when it builds
it runs and it runs and it's right here
where it says hello world
okay not the greatest experiences but
hey it actually runs so let's start
creating some code
so if I were to say int I equals three
and I were to say I plus equal four
and then
CW Snippets do work so CW is a snippet
so hit Tab and I can say
door string interpolation here the value
of I is
like so but I'm not sure this is correct
so I put a break point here
I hit F5
let's run this
hits the break point I can step over I
can Mouse over and see the value I can
come over here my locals window and look
at the value of I I can set watch values
as well and so on so it's it's getting
closer to a full Visual Studio
experience but still it's it's that
light experience of vs code
now
I'm going to show you a quirk so if I
were to say console.write
Y is your name
and then I want to say string name
equals
console.reline
so and then let's just console right
line that says
hello and your name
okay and I think I've got an extra
set of brackets down here
okay so a couple things here first of
all if you can see that there's
squigglies underneath the console read
line the reason for that is because the
console read line can technically return
a null string
but yet my string is not marked as
nullable this is a newer feature in.net
if we were to go over to our console or
our CS project file we can see right
here nullable is enabled
which means it's going to yell at us
every time we have a potentially
nullable string going into a
non-nullable mark string or other
variable types so we can work around
this by saying yeah we know
can we now
okay and we're good but now let's run
this application again
and we do
hits the break point great let's take
the break point off let's run it again
keep running it so the value of I is 7.
that's it
all right so what's happening
well
there is a I'm not sure it's a feature
but they kind of Mark it as a feature
that if you go over here to your vs code
look at the launch settings and you look
at right down here where it says console
it says he mounts over it says the
internal counts console does not support
reading from the console
which is super helpful
okay because that's you know we don't
ever do that in consoles
so what you can do
take that out control space brings up a
list of our intellisense our drop down
list we get to choose which one we want
and I prefer the external terminal so
external or integrated terminal either
one will work
and now if we hit F5
it's going to launch the external
terminal window we can say my name is
Tim
and it goes away why does it go away
well
that's something that we as c-sharp
developers should know about but
console read line at the end just to
pause things
okay my name is
still Tim
and it's not printing anything out they
never actually printed it out is that it
yep
read lines in the wrong place
okay
it's always fun to do this on stage
all right my name is now Tom hello Tom
okay so that's how we debug that's how
we have Redline that's how we run our
applications
so let's
um let's make some changes now
um let's go on to add a class library
and again I'm going to dive back out
into my other Journal just for the
visual sake of it I'm going to keep open
this window so you can kind of see it
hopefully
and we're going to say dot net new
class Library class lib
we're going to give a name
and this name is going to be helperlib
okay we see it pop up right over there
now we need to add that to the solution
so.net
sln
simple demo Dot sln
add
helperlib
slash helperlib dot CS proj
okay we've now added that to the
solution
by the way if you were to say dot net
sln list
you see which projects are actually in
your solution
okay so let's
do the next thing we need to do let's go
to change the directory to helper lib
and in this directory now that I'm in
the director I can work on the
particular project that's there instead
of having to specify where's the project
which means I can do things like
dot net add package so you want to add
nuget package
let's just pick one
I hope the Wi-Fi works
there you go it's not about a nougat
package now again this is where it
starts to push you you just say hey I
don't like that syntax I don't want to
do that syntax because that's that's
terribly hard to have that one line
um
that's all it's doing so
just go ahead and put that in there copy
and paste another project whatever you
want to do so again this is where we
want to push ourselves to know our our
c-sharp products better and better
because when we do we know at the
fundamental level how things work then
it's very easy to make changes like I
can get rid of dapper just by
backspacing now
okay
so let's go back to our product we're
going to change back out
we can say dot net build make sure
things still build after I made all
those changes yes they do that's great
now
let's go to the
um
while we're here let's change directory
into the console UI
rsa.net run so if you don't want to use
BS code all and hit the F5 just say.net
run in the project directory
and there we go what's my name
it's Tim now
hello Tim we're good to go okay so we
have options with this
now let's clear the screen again and
we're going to change the directory up
one
and we're back in the in the solution
directory and while we're here let's do
this let's add our class library to our
console project
so
dot net add
console UI slash console ui.cs proj
reference
and this is helper lib slash helper lib
dot CS proj
now what did that do if we go back over
here to our console look at the Cs
project file all it did was do this so
again you don't have to know the command
line for that you can just type in the
the item group
okay
so with that just to make sure again
that it still runs let's come back over
here and just hit F5 make sure that
nothing broke
good still working
okay
so a couple things in here let's go to
our our class Library let's get rid of
class one
let's start over
so we're going to say new file I love
this so we're going to say messages.cs
and I have again a blank file so it's a
DOT CS file but it's up to me what to do
with that so I need to know namespace
helper lib
I'm going to say public class
let's call this messages since that's
the name of the file we're in we'll say
public void is happening with typing
that's really good
um
say hi
and
hello NDC okay now
this is my obligatory we're going to
demo don't put your data or user
interface in your class Library please
okay but now that I have this here I can
come over to my program.cs and I can
reference it right so
I want to reference the messages
so messages don't have the using uh
director for that
if I hit control dot here I still get my
quick actions refactoring I can hit
enter to add the using at the very top
so now at the very top we have using
helper lib
and so now I can say messages
equals
new
I can say messages dots
say hi
and with that
if we run this my name is Tim and hello
NDC as well
okay
so that's how we reference our class
library is how we access the class
library for my other project that's how
we use the quick actions refactoring we
go back over to the messages
we'll also see we have code lens
so if you click let me just um
go away
it's too big sometimes
there we go if you look on top of your
methods and on top of your classes you
have how many references there are this
used to be a visual studio Enterprise
feature in 2019 now is in Visual Studio
2022 Community Edition and also in vs
code
so you can see where the reference is
you can even click on the reference
they'll click on it and it takes you
right to the code so you can actually
navigate through your code that way also
just like in visual studio if you hit
F12 on say messages it takes you to
where that class definition is so we
have a lot of the same features of
Visual Studio it's just in a smaller
faster package
okay
so let's do this let's start over
and we're going to close out this
entirely
and we'll move on to demo number two
because I'm sure that not everybody here
just wants to build console applications
so let's do this dot net new solution
and recall this name Blazer demo
and we're going to say.net new blazer
server
and the name will be Blazer UI
now this is the full Blazer server
template there is let's just um
dot net let's clear a screen first
.net new
lists
we go here if we look at the the Blazer
Solutions or Blazer templates here we
see Blazer server we also see the Blazer
server Dash empty that's the new.net 7
template that has basically nothing in
it doesn't even have bootstrap so it's
pretty much just hello worldly to run it
it's not great for demos so we're not
going to use it there's also the Blazer
webassembly and now we also have.net
Mario Blazer but again we're just using
the uh the first Blazer server
okay so now you have that let's say.net
sln
Blazer demo.sln
add
laser UI slash Blazer uis Dot
CS proj
there we go now we have those two we
could say code dot open up our vs code
we have scaffold out a full project
and yes we want to create those those
elements there which is that vs code
file with us two things there okay now a
couple things here first of all if that
doesn't fire for whatever reason first
of all go to your program.cs
file and just open it up and wait a
second that's probably the best way to
trigger that
um there is a way if you go to the view
menu go command palette and say net
generate assets for build and debug that
sometimes works however if it doesn't
come on automatically it probably won't
work there either
restart vs code or look at your code
make sure you don't have a malform
project
okay so with this let's do this let's
um just go ahead and hit F5 see what
happens
it's always good to just try out the
very beginning
there we go so we have web project we go
the counter page of course counter
click me it all works that's Blazer UI
the one thing to note let's zoom in here
if you notice localhost 5118 if you're
familiar with the Web projects in dot
net a five prefix the 5000 series means
you got HTTP not https and sure enough
your connection is not secure which is
not ideal right
so let's fix that
so we'll close out of
this
minimize hit stop
so back over to
our launch.json launch.json is the place
to look for basically everything about
launching your application
and in here we want to add a new section
so I put it right under the pre-launch
task
so we're going to say
launch settings profile
we give it a profile name I get the
profile name of https but where to get
that name from
so to go over to properties of your
project again this is where knowing more
about your project and how it actually
works is really helpful this works in
Visual Studio as well so you go to the
launch settings.json under properties
and you'll see in here you have profiles
this is there's isas at the top of those
profiles the first one is HTTP the
second one is https now full Visual
Studio says we know what you really want
you want https so that's what we'll
default to
but for vs code it's not making that
assumption for you therefore it's going
to grab the first one by default which
is not what you technically want so or
at least not usually so instead I chose
this name now that name can be anything
you want that could be Tim's cool web
application Runner thing
not a great name but you could use that
name in which case you have to go over
to your launch.json and put that whole
long string there
just use https okay with that if we now
hit F5 to run our application
and if we look
we're now on the 7000 Port series and
we have a secure connection
okay so we're using https as opposed to
http which is more in line with how we
actually use our website therefore it's
more in line with how we should be
testing our site
now that's pretty cool but let's um
actually close this stuff out
and let's go over to our pages and let's
go to this index page and
we're going to run this first
wait for it to load I'm going to shift
it over
so let's shift this over to the left or
the right third and we'll grab a vs code
there we go
and
now I I've noticed that it says hello
world that's not very personal so let's
go ahead and change that to hello NDC
we save that and nothing happens okay
because we don't have hot reload
yet we're gonna turn hot reload on so
let's undo that change we want to make
that change live
so let's close this out let's close that
out and maximize this
I get the hot reload well we go back
over to our launch.json and we have our
pre-launch instead of build we can say
watch
now
if we run this again
and let's move this over to
our two-thirds on the left
and go back over to our index.razer now
if I were to say hello NDC and wait for
a second without touching anything we've
got hot reload all right so we're
getting closer to our actual same
environment we have in Visual Studio the
same features we have the code lens and
the the quick actions refactoring we
have the
um the lookups and everything we need
but we're not quite there yet because
the Eagles Eye among you will always
noticed
that's uh Port 5000 again
oops
okay
so
it's a bit of a quirk
I'd love to find someone that tells you
the better way so please see me after if
it's a better way because that'd be
awesome however what I have found is the
best way to solve this problem is
actually going to your launch
settings.json is to grab
this profile right here cut it out come
down here
face it back in change the order so your
first one is https
okay like I said a little hacky
but if I run this now
oh I'm already running it
let's restart this because that was a
major change
okay so now if I run this
I see that I am on a secure connection
and if I were to go back or the razor
page let's
move us back over
let's get rid of that Syria problem I
hate that thing
okay and it's gone so now we have our
hot reload we have SSL we have all the
fun tools and and tricks with vs code
running with blazer on our site all
right
okay
so
we're not done yet
because why would we be
all right let's go ahead and get rid of
this session
and we're going to maximize this again
and I want to put in a connection string
now we're not going to do data access
and all the rest you all can do that but
I'm going to do is I'm going to go to my
app settings.json
I'm going to say let's add a connection
string
connection strings
let's say default
let's say this is
from app settings
Json okay not the place you should be
put in your connection string app
settings.json not the place at least not
locally
so
if I were to want to access this let's
go to the um a different page just to
not mess things up let's go to counter
page and write a below the category ask
for the connection string so we're going
to say inject
and we're going to say I configuration
config
and then down here
we're going to say H2 not HW H2 how
about that and we're going to say at
config Dot
get connection string
and ask for default
okay
so if we were to run our application
again
let's go to the counter page and now
this is from app settings.json
hopefully I've not blown anybody's mind
quite yet okay but we have the
connection string from our app
settings.json but again that's not the
right place to put it when you're local
what you want to do instead is you want
to get it from secrets.json
now if you're in Visual Studio you right
click on your project and say manage
user secrets
but we don't have that in vs code well
kind of I'll show you that in a minute
but there is a way I do this manually
and I'm going to do that manually is you
go back over here to Let's Open Up Our
CS project file first we can see it so
let's uh close all and go over to
our CS project file there we go there's
our basic CS project file I'll open this
up and then kind of move it down below
so you can see what happens
and we're going to clear the screen
we're going to say dot net
user Dash secrets
init
it just didn't find it
oh you know why I know why
we need to change the directory
all right let's try it again
so net user Dash secrets and Knits
and the only thing it actually does is
it puts this user secrets in our CS
project file and it puts a good there
that guid starts with 17e if we go over
let's open up a new version of File
Explorer
and if we look it's gonna be a little
bit small but I will put the notes for
later
percent app data
Microsoft
slash user secrets
okay these are all my user Secrets don't
don't tell
but you'll not see in here yet a folder
that is with a 17e you'll not see a
folder that starts at 17e yet
now if you're not familiar user secrets
are not stored with your project and the
reason why is because that way you can
put things like your local connection
strings in there without it going into
Source control and bothering the rest of
your team
so I want to put my connection string in
here
the way I do that is go back to our
command line we can move us up now
and we can say
dot net
user Dash secrets
set
where I say connection strings colon
default
and then this is from user secrets
like so you put your your key and then
your value the key is separated by
colons if you have a nesting thing so
we're already nested one level lens we
use one semicolon or one full colon
okay
done successfully saved I go back over
here we're going to see that we now have
a folder called 17e
if we drag this secrets.json in here
we'll see connection strings colon
default this is for our user Secrets now
um let's
hit F5 first
just to see it run
but we're going to talk more about that
file
okay so counter this is some user
secrets so we've overridden our app
settings.json with user secrets
but it's a little funky
so
let's get rid of this
this works
but it's collapsed
and the way that the.net command line
talks about this and the documentation
is it's a feature not a bug
I personally don't prefer to see that
out that way but you could go in there
and manually change it or
you can right click on your project and
say manage user secrets
and open it up
you see how I did that it's actually not
built into to the c-sharp
[Music]
extension go back to extensions and look
there's another extension from Adrian
I'm not going to pronounce his last name
but Adrian has the.net core user Secrets
all it does is when you right click on
it your CS project file if there's not
already a Secrets associated with your
project it's going to create one and
that's going to take you to that file
that's all it's going to do
okay so it's a simple little extension
it's an awesome job
all right so again if I come back my
project here if I get rid of this I
can't remember 17e
got rid of it
and then I were to right click on my CS
project file and say manage user secrets
it says hey
I can't find a user secret for your
project you want to initialize one yes
and initialize one but it's empty
okay and it's four F7 now it creates a
new one so it doesn't actually reuse one
because it's not actually remembering
what your project was it just creates a
random good and says hey there's your
secrets so you can restart if you want
you can also change that random give it
to something else if you wanted to why
bother
okay so in here
connection strings
oops
stick with the Json format
default
this is my
new Secret
okay
and if we were to run this again just to
verify that it's pulling from the new
Secret
this is my new Secret
okay
so that's user Secrets inside of your vs
code
okay we're not done yet
let's keep going
so let's actually close out of Visual
Studio that's good enough for now
and let's try to make my life a little
miserable
so
let's go to demo three
we're gonna say open Terminal
and for demo three we're going to
say.net new solution
name
form demo app
you thought I was gonna avoid that
didn't you
okay it's not a valid
yes because I didn't say name
you get talking and typing at the same
time it doesn't really work
brain disconnects okay so we have my.net
news solution with a name of form demo
app so dot net new WPF dash dash name
WPF demo
or essay.net sln
form demo app dot sln add
WPF demo slash
wpfdemo.cs proj
okay so you've Associated to them but
why do we stop there because that just
seems too simple of a demo so.net
new
informs
we're going to say the name is spelled
right the name is going to be winforms
demo so same solution
yep spelling huh thank you
there we go
okay so dot net
sln
form demo app
Dot sln
add
winforms demo slash winforms
demo.cs proj
okay
and now let's just open up in code
so we have the WPF demo and we have win
forms now which means we have two
different user interfaces in one vs code
and says hey we're missing some build
assets we want to build it sure I do
yeah which one
can I start one at a time genius let's
start with uh win form because it was
the the first
so we now can if we hit F5
launch win forms I mean it's I know it's
exciting demo but there you go we're
actually running win forms now a couple
of caveats here first of all that's not
cross-platform so if you're on Mac or
you're on Linux
you can build it well actually I'm sorry
you can open it up and you can make
changes to it you just can't run it okay
but if you're on Windows and if you're
just bored and want to have something
fun to do go ahead and open up your
your winiform application now
with that being said
let's go back here what if I decide hey
I don't want to have win forms launched
I want to have WPF launch or the option
to launch either one
that's more in line what you might do in
a real world scenario
so go to launch.json the first thing I'm
going to do
is I'm going to come up here to where it
says name
where it says.net core launch console
this name if you go back over here to
run debug you'll see
dot net core launch console
so we can change this to be something
else let's do that let's call this
win forms
now we go to the view menu and say
command palette dot net generate assets
for build and debug it's gonna say you
want to replace the existing I sure do
hit yes
now I'm going to choose the WPF demo
which didn't actually overwrite my
winning forms
we come down here we now see that.net
core launch console has been created
for my WPF I can just say WPF
so my drop down now I can choose to
change the jpf I can launch this
application
wait for it to run
and I have a WPF application launching
but I can come back here I can go back
to win forms and I can run win forms
now
with that let's do a couple things just
to show off again that things still work
so go over a program dot actually
form1.cs which is our form Windows Form
we can say VAR I equals three and we can
put our break point in here to make sure
things are going to work and then we can
hit well let's go over to a run
debugging make sure it's Wind forms
we're launching
and if we do
doesn't hit the break point
interesting it should
we'll get there
so the other thing we can do is we go
over to our WPF project we can make some
changes to our main window.saml
the key here is there's not a lot of
help so you need to know about
stack panel notice there's no real
intellisense for me
and it's not really helping with the
closing tags either
and if I want to say text block
and say hello NDC
it's not really helping you there either
so it's not a great tool for WPF editing
it's not a great tool for winform
editing winiform is you know worse
scenario because now you're going to the
form one designer where it says hey
don't actually change stuff in here
because we do this stuff only the Wii is
now you so good luck go ahead and
writing your your win forms in your
C sharp I've done it it's messy don't
prefer that so it still does work and if
we launch this just to see that the UPF
has changed
it does work but
yeah
there you go super tiny but it does say
hello NDC we'll zoom in there just to
prove that yes it does work
okay so with that we've got the
opportunity to bounce back and forth
between more than one startup project we
have the ability to rename our startup
projects we have the ability to debug we
have the ability to make changes to even
projects that aren't necessarily full
featured full support in vs code like
winforms WPF the story gets a little bit
more messy with Maui so I haven't
created Maui demo for you yet because
that's kind of like a more inflamed kind
of thing than it is actually a working
project but
um but you can do a lot with vs code
so let's do this we're going to pop over
here and just do a quick recap
and then we're going to have some time
for questions so recap extensions first
of all C sharp by Microsoft which is the
Omni sharp variant of C sharp so get
that extension also get the.net core
user secrets that's a great extension by
Adrian it's really helpful for your
day-to-day that's all I really use for
my c-sharp development
now.net commands dot net new list that's
when it helps me tremendously when I
forget once the command for an empty
class library or class library for
eraser Pages or something like that.net
solution the solution add the project
dot net run dot net watch so I didn't do
it but on the command line if you decide
hey I want to bypass vs code entirely
and just watch this on the command line
you just run.net watch in the directory
where your project is and it will run
watch it for you
dot net publish so when you're ready to
publish your application running.net
publish will package it up for you again
it's very very helpful to know how to do
that command how to run it locally and
test it because the fact that that's
what's going to be in your cicd pipeline
for pushing your application out to
wherever it gets deployed
and then.net user Secrets again know how
to use those users user Secrets
appropriately
all right vs code the launch.json tweaks
we only play a launch.json that's the
place we're going to spend most of your
time making tweaks the first one if
you're working a console application you
actually want a console change it to
either integrated terminal which is the
terminal inside of a vs code but
separate from the build window
which means it can get the console
Reliance or use external terminal in
order to launch a separate window
uh launch today's profile this we were
to add to your launch.json and this is
what's going to launch on that https or
whatever uh flavor you decide to launch
on and then finally the pre-launch tasks
you can either have it build if you want
to build your application and just have
it run without hot reload or if you
wanted to have hot reload you change it
to watch
okay so that
what questions do you have
far back you might need a shout or you
can come up here
whichever
what's the I'm sorry what
the unit testing experience good
question so if you have unit tests which
I didn't put in the demo but if you have
unit test then all you need to do is go
to command line and say.net test I
believe it is it will run those in the
command line
so there isn't a GUI in vs code that I
know of but you'll see it in the command
line see your test which one's passed
which ones fail and so forth
good question don't have a specific
answer for you
I can look it up for you
good question so the question is hey is
there an advantage to having a solution
file when we're just using vs code and
running CS proj there's a few things
that require a solution file and the
biggest one is if you want to then work
with anything else vs for Mac vs for
full Visual Studio or writer or anything
else it's just easier if you have that
solution file so it's that cross cross
tool access and that's something too is
everything we did today with the
exception of flipping the HTTP and the
https everything we did was really
outside of our code when it came to
configuring vs code which means that we
can then use visual studio and not have
a disruption
so that's why it's nice to have a
solution because then you're not causing
A disruption for anybody else when they
go to open it there's not a good way in
Visual Studio yet to just open a project
without already creating a solution for
you
so good question like questions
so the question is you know there's tons
of plugins out there how you choose
which ones
to use
um here's my philosophy on tooling and
in plugins and it's served me pretty
well start with nothing
and just do your job
and then when you can't go any further
we say hey I'm really I'm continually
hitting this wall then go look for a
plug-in to help you now obviously in
this case we're going to start off with
a C sharp plug-in and I would say the
user secrets too because that's a pretty
easy one but if you start adding plugins
just to add plugins then you might not
actually make your life better you might
make it worse so start off with find
your pain points first and then go find
the solution for that pain point if
there is one there's not a ton of
plugins for C sharp specifically when it
comes to vs code I'm not sure there's a
whole lot that is needed
okay
are there security concerns of the
plugins
anything you run your computer that's
going to touch your source code and you
think through but by and large they're
open source you can look at them and see
what's going on
okay other questions
all right well thanks for being here I
thanks for sticking out for the end of
the session have a great trip home and
thanks for being NDC
foreign